my colleague from the nfl media group
who dropped a fascinating nugget about
eric weddle and so much more back here
on the rich eisen show ian rappaport at
rap sheet how are you ian
all right rich ask me the question
uh
what's the question what do you got what
is it most important question that you
just went through right only thing that
people want to know ask me the question
uh
how how what's the state of eric
weddle's beard
uh sources tell me yes that eric
weddle's beard is roughly two inches
long oh and i would say two centimeters
thick so i would not describe it as like
one of those like jimmy anvil night
heart hanging here
fairly bushy um and
i mean it's today is
january something yeah
and you got
about a month before the super bowl
so like
if we take it where it is now you
project it forward through the super
bowl i think we could get like a real
like
you know bushy type beard action like uh
you know some of the classics i think
he's in a good spot and something that
this you know expect this to continue to
grow well classics are like you know uh
rutherford b hayes cough drop brothers
or obviously ryan fitzpatrick that
that's what we're talking about in terms
of epic beards
what about kesel i feel like kiso had a
good one okay brett keisel very good i
mean please my god it's like uh it was
like dan haggerty the red-headed dude
from game of thrones that's true he had
a good one oh yeah tormund tormund
torment
all right
game of thrones
you know what man i'll tell you les need
is just he's just constantly like
there's no
he's he is he ever inside the box
because there it's crazy that so where
how did this come about it just came
about because fuller's hurt and
let's you know why not whittle right is
that the way this happened scores hurt
and you know taylor rap is in concussion
protocol uh this really came together
i think yesterday um
you know it's funny do you follow jalen
ramsey on twitter sure
i've missed what he said though still
he tweeted
at 1 30 a.m
dylan ramsey
has an ear to the personnel department
of the los angeles rams sure
he has been ahead of every crazy move
they've made with weird cryptic tweets i
also follow my good friend jaylen ramsey
on twitter and i will now be
uh following him even more closely
because when he tweets cryptic stuff
crazy things happen and i would say this
like i listen to your clip of little
and yes he is
done preparing for the season he has
done doing that long grind that's not
what this is this is preparing for one
game and then maybe another game and
then maybe another game this is very
different
and you know how many snaps will you
play will he play 60 snaps i doubt it
but he's going to be there helping and i
imagine it will it'll be beneficial i
love it and i was reading out a list two
of players who are going to be back in
time for the playoffs
um you know j.j watt expected to be back
and that very game derek henry the week
after and then there's a trio of packers
bhaktiari played um 20 some odd snaps
in week 18 jair alexander and zadaria
smith today right like so
uh designated for a turner are we gonna
see all those packers back do you think
in a week and a half
uh also some other singing at the news
for the green bay packers yes aaron
rodgers is practicing
today is wednesday and aaron rodgers is
practicing so
not only did you get david bachiri back
you get jared alexander probably back
you get sedaria smith probably back
which is massive i mean he is it will be
like as a third down rusher but that's
okay i mean that's basically what bob
miller is right dramatic impact
and then aaron rodgers is practicing and
the reason i say that is just rogers
hasn't practiced on a wednesday in like
a couple months
so this indicates that his little toe
his poor little toe
uh is
as healthy as it has been so
everyone is beaten up and the packers
are the opposite
ian rappaport here on the rich eisen
show
what happened uh with the giants
deliberation to chat with joe judge on a
monday and then decide on tuesday yeah
we're done what happened there
yeah it was interesting because you know
i feel like they probably knew on monday
from what i understand those
conversations
weren't like um
you know
tell me your plans for next year i mean
it was he told them his plans for next
year but it wasn't the kind of thing
where like they sat down and plotted out
what was going to happen
like they talked about various other
topics but it didn't sound like they
spent a ton of time on like the actual
plans for next year
that to me means they probably knew and
you know he i think he left his team and
his pl his coaches and his players with
plans for the off-season but i talked to
a couple players yesterday and they felt
like something was up because the
meetings were still going on and like
the more you wait the more it makes you
think that something may happen
um and you know for me it's interesting
like i've known joe judge for
you know more than 10 years i've known
him since he was a 20 year old special
team at mississippi state
he is a very good football coach
and he got his team to play extremely
hard and
to believe in him and i think what the
players said was real
um the results weren't good enough
and there's a lot of reasons why an
officer coordinator that he really
didn't want the general manager he
certainly didn't want a third string
quarterback but at the end nobody cared
about any of that it was just were the
results good enough or not and they
clearly were not well i'll just say too
uh ian it's just weird comments like
players from outside the organization
are still trying to come back in that's
how good the culture is despite
what we're seeing uh calling washington
clown show also
you know the the the pointing out when
the patriots made the super bowl in the
year where they beat the rams they all
thought they were getting fired
mid-season all you got to do look at the
team was seven and two mid-season and
it's just like what you know all the
patriots writers were like that's a lie
like that is just not true
and then the surrender formation that
doesn't sound like
the person you just described you know
what i'm saying
ian yeah and
you're right and so
you know a couple things first of all
like i have no doubt that belichick with
the fear of god and those assistants
you know during that year that he's
talking about um
it's just
it's not reality to say it so like was
joe judge himself nervous that he was
getting fired based on the way belichick
was treating them when they were losing
like probably
but that was also probably not reality
um
you know i think the the lack of
awareness
there's a lot of things that go into
being a head coach there's a lot of
things
and
especially for the inexperienced guys or
the guys who haven't stepped out of new
england they do seem to a lot of them
share a trait of
not having a really good sense of what's
happening around them
and
shutting it all out and just putting
your head down and working because in
new england that's what you do
you just you focus on your job you do
your job belichick handles the rest you
do your job well you become a good
candidate and you interview and you get
a head coaching job but sometimes
you do so without the global awareness
necessary to be a head coach and i think
of all the things that hurt joe judge
that was a big part of it is that what
happened with brian flores down in miami
what happened there
yeah
yeah i think with flores it was a little
different that was more of that you know
forest doesn't need to prove anything as
a football coach you know with two as
his quarterback he won nine and ten
games i mean that is impressive right i
mean
that's some really good coaching and yes
he coaches hard and he works with a step
hard
the people who are devoted to him are
insanely devoted to him
and he is a very good football coach
this really came down
to the owner feeling like he needed to
pick one
with you know grier and forest
relationship deteriorating and you know
this has been going on for about a month
so at one point i thought one was in
trouble then the other
then i probably thought late last week
that this was going to be okay
but like you know you know my world rich
and like a lot of the things
that we hear
you know unless i'm talking to stephen
ross or unless i'm talking to an owner
you're not really sure what's going to
go on because one person makes a
decision
or the giants gives two people so i
thought it was going to be okay but in
the end stephen ross decided that
um
you know he needed to make a decision
that these two couldn't work well
together
um
and he chose the gm not the head coach
oh man why like what happened there what
did happen
do you know
yeah um you know you look at the ways
that it broke down i mean obviously
there was the failed desean watson trade
uh and i believe everybody was on the
same page you met you dude the building
was on the same page you do you do like
that bro because again that that was
like two weeks before the season charles
robinson yahoo remember that report and
then um and then
getting permission to talk to him
i was at traverse watching the horses
and i was like can i please just enjoy
it
that's your life man so but you know but
then and then getting permission to
actually speak with him and then doing
so in the middle of a season
you know like
with with all of the the um
you know legal
stuff which is the way that i guess we
all refer to it that's still out there
so they were all on board it's not it's
not like was it a tua thing that they
they didn't that one guy didn't want him
and the other guy did or
was it a tua thing is that what this is
too
or no um
i i feel like flores definitely wanted
him i think greer was on board
was he as all in as everyone like i
don't know and you know now of course he
has tua
um but when they tried to make the trade
they were all on board until stephen
ross said i'm not doing this until the
legal situation is wrapped up
um but that you know the desire to trade
for a quarterback and then not
eventually doing it definitely creates
problems
uh then there you know some other
the way things were handled some other
personnel moves and there's
you know i think one of the tough things
is when you're brian floys and you come
in you evaluate the roster and you say
all right this guy's not good enough
this guy's not good enough we need to
trade this guy
and there's no way around it rich like
these are chris grier's guys
so like
that probably is
i'm sure that made it a difficult work
in the atmosphere as well
ian rappaport here uh on the rich eisen
show
okay and so um
you mentioned about a choice that
stephen ross had to make felt compelled
to make was forced to make however you
want to phrase it between his coach and
his general manager he chose the gm over
the coach
is is it a choice in seattle between
russ
or pete carroll
for john schneider if he if he is is is
in danger i i don't know why that would
be but
i know some seattle fans are beginning
to chafe because that's the way it seems
to be
although you know russ they got a couple
years left of contractual control and
pete's signed
through 2025. could they run it back or
are we off that we're just like it's a
choice that one can't they can't coexist
anymore what's going on in seattle
in there i don't think it's a choice i
do think they need to make sure that one
that
jody allen the owner wants all of them
there
and this is about just like what i was
talking about with the owner thing like
when
you know when all of us talk about
coaches who bear safe or on the hot seat
or coming back and you know there's been
reports
on everyone i mean there are reports
that
gender is coming back the report i mean
there's
there's all sorts of reports on these
coaching stuff but like nobody knows
what's going to happen in seattle
because as far as i can tell nobody's
talking to jody allen and that is the
voice that matters and i don't even know
that anyone there knows what's going to
happen but i think what it's going to be
is not a choice
i think it is going to be a are we on
the same page moving forward with
with what we want to do and if the
answer is yes then i think they're all
going to come back if the answer is no
then it's like who's not on board and
why not and how does she end up dealing
with that i think that's more of what it
is i don't know why why wouldn't you
want everyone back you know i mean they
they have a they have a history together
uh the question is is that is there a
bridge and too much water underneath it
that's the general sense because of the
way that russ was
you know uh talking or people on his
behalf talking
um
right around next month last year you
know what i mean like so
right other than that like for himself
that was the craziest thing once i saved
like pete hasn't forgotten man campaign
right you know what i mean like pete has
not forgotten how to coach and russ we
saw what happened the last two weeks of
the season which by the way like if he
was you know supposed to sit out and
wait for his finger to heal for as long
as it probably needed to like that kind
of makes sense right even though he said
it's not my finger and all that business
that's why i'm asking because the
general you know conventional wisdom
whether it's
wise or not is that these two can't
coexist anymore run is over somebody's
gonna have to like if somebody says
pete's staying russ is like screw it i'm
out of here let's get me out of here or
vice versa
right
i mean you kind of hit on the main
problem
is that
they played so well at the end of the
year
so like might you look at that and say
okay if this quarterback is healthy we
are still good and they ran the ball so
well at the end i mean rashad penny who
like
was given up for dead many times looked
awesome
so
could i say to myself if i was on the
seahawks like all right we'll just do
this again next year like we can be good
again and maybe this year was an anomaly
or maybe for the seahawks maybe
you know i don't know what the market's
going to be for russell wilson
but
what if it's not as good as it was last
year
then do you say all right we're not
going to trade him for just one one
because that doesn't make sense so we're
just gonna bring him back like there's
so much that goes into it and
like i
as someone who does this for a living
i'm having a hard time projecting what's
going to happen
um because i really don't know
ian rapport few minutes left with my
colleague from the nfl media group uh
who next what next are there any next
and those are two ways of me saying how
come caroline is firing a ton of
assistance and matt rules still sitting
there
uh and also the harbaugh check on
whether rich versace and mayok are
coaching in general managing for their
jobs right now what do you think
about saint houston too um
i mean
david uh come on
that would be ridiculous i mean because
colley got handed easily one of the
worst hands in coaching and i mean if if
urban meyer got
handed one of the greatest hands in
coaching collie got the worst hand like
he got he got seven two he got the doyle
brunson he got seven two off suit man
you know and and and davis mills looked
terrific by the end of the year i
thought i thought he did yeah you know
so i would say if you didn't know what
round davis mills was drafted in you'd
be talking not you
we don't we're talking differently about
it of course yeah
you know so all right so kali mike uh
i'll give you the floor then on on on
the what next
then ian
um all right so we have seattle we
talked about um kali
possibly they are evaluating all aspects
of the football w football department so
i will
keep an eye on that one
you have
uh mayok and
vesatia
um my understanding is they are still
going to do a search and i'm pretty sure
they have to do a search right
like i think they have to do a
who's going to be our coach church to do
it real you know not like the [ __ ]
whatever they did when guten was hired
right which is not really a search
um
i don't know if versace comes back
obviously it's you know i would say he
has more of a chance now
um because the team is good they're in
the playoffs but definitely not a sure
thing and for mayok you know some limbo
as well um teams in the playoffs that's
good
but you know how to deal with
so much trouble with so many of this
first round draft picks i mean that is
you know
obviously alarming um
so yeah we'll be keeping your eye on
that one uh as well and what about
carolina
i guess last one for you then what about
i think with carolina that's one where
you know
rule has a long contract
i think they still believe he is a good
coach
he what he did fire some assistance and
is looking for a new oc
but they haven't really had a
quarterback so
you know this this would have been my
argument to bring back joe judge which
obviously would have fallen on deaf ears
but how do we know how good a coach not
real is when he had good quarterback
play he was 3-0
and then he had bad quarterback playing
he wasn't as good so
how do you really judge i think is one
thing that carolina campers are going
through
ian rappaport i appreciate it look for
my calls and texts and you see him all
the time anyway and then uh we got you
you double duty four and a half hours
saturday four on sunday for game day
morning pumped
thanks playoffs baby i'm excited
and you're psyched about uh buck
showalter is the mets manager we haven't
spoken about that you got to be right
yeah you should be um for you know the
next two years i think it's going to be
great
take care of yourself ian thanks for the
time take care okay okay there you go
ian rappaport everybody hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here